rumors of gpt4 are in the air neuron
Transmissions is now solved in closed
form and mind reading is a thing now
it's Monday and welcome to ml news
[Music]
hello and welcome to ml news this is
your regular update of what's going on
in the machine learning and AI World our
first story is the most interesting one
brain reading is more and more becoming
a thing there is a paper called seeing
beyond the brain conditional diffusion
models with sparse mask modeling for
vision decoding in this paper the
authors give a visual stimulus to a
subject a real human and then look at
their brain waves this is non-invasive
this is fmri brain scans and from that
reading of the fmri they're able to
decode what the person is seeing you can
see right here on the top you have
visual stimuli and on the bottom you
have the reconstructed images now what
you'll be able to see is that the pixels
don't exactly match however the semantic
content is very often the same now this
is done via aligning the latent spaces
of the encoders for the brain data and
encoders from from images and this has
been a long-standing problem because the
training data that exists to map what
people are seeing from their brain waves
to the image space is just super sparse
but the authors here go around that by
pre-training on unlabeled fmri data and
first get a very very good Auto encoder
on that data going then the latent space
can be determined compressed and then
from that latent space we can learn a
conditional image diffusion decoder in
order to map the visual stimuli to the
encoding of the brain waves so the
Paradigm that we see in deep learning
where you want to do some unsupervised
pre-training first because you have much
more unlabeled data and only then
include the task specific data and learn
that on top of the unsupervised
pre-trained models also holds in the
field of brain computer interfaces
apparently so it's pretty cool that
we're more and more getting the chance
to peek into people's brains now this
isn't yet a full thought reader or
anything like this essentially they
disambiguate between I believe leave
some 100 different classes of labels but
it's still very very cool that you can
essentially reconstruct just from
Reading brain waves what kind of image
the person is seeing and what about is
in the image in a related article
neurosciencenews.com writes that brain
machine interface device predicts
internal speech now this is a little bit
different in that it's actually invasive
so this is an interface directly to the
brain but it is able to predict internal
speech which means speech that you just
internally think to yourself it is able
to decode that now it is not able to
decode arbitrary speech I believe they
go up to about eight words or something
like this so it's not yet exactly super
accurate but we are making big big
progress in that front all right Next
News
[Music]
Ramin Hassani writes that they've
published a new article in nature
machine intelligence and solved a
differential equation that's been long
standing without a closed form solution
we now have that closed form solution
and it concerns the interactions between
neurons this is a major benefit for
people who want to implement
biologically inspired sort of
biologically plausible neural networks
because previously you'd have to have
some sort of an ode solver in order to
even model that connection properly and
now that there's a closed form solution
you can essentially just forward and
back prop through that formula and the
absolute coolest thing is that they have
implemented this in both High torch and
tensorflow so you can technically build
in this directly into your architectures
today now it's not guaranteed to be like
a lot better than what we currently have
in terms of neuron neuron connection but
that's not the point the point is to get
to a place where we can simulate
biologically plausible neural networks
as well as possible and from those
potentially learn something about the
brain and we might actually get some
inspiration for how to even improve our
artificial neural network architectures
from this so check out the paper and the
repository in case you're interested
Alberto Romero on substack has an
article called gpt4 rumors from Silicon
Valley this is a summary of things that
people whatever people means talk about
currently around Jeep D4 so open AI has
been announcing like tiny bits of the
next iteration of their language models
here and there and there used to be an
interview by Sam Altman where he said
gpt4 isn't really gonna be that much
bigger than gpt3 and it's probably still
going to be in the text domain it's
probably going to be a bit more aligned
to humans a bit more you know learning
from Human feedback and so on and people
were kind of like a tiny bit
disappointed I guess because it's not
all we're gonna build the next giant
thing but now more and more rumors are
coming out that in fact gpt4 might be
very well what they claim colossal so
another scale up of two orders of
magnitude or something like this in
terms of numbers of parameters or even
three orders of magnitude although some
rumors claim that it is going to be
sparse so there's not really like a
one-to-one comparison on the other hand
there are also a lot of rumors that
claim that GPT 4 is going to be
multi-modal after all so including text
images videos and so on basically
anything they can get their fingers on
so we'll see which one of these turns
out to be true it's very well possible
that they first aimed at just sort of
improving gpt3 and then all of a sudden
with recent developments around
diffusion models and so on they've now
gone into the direction of you know
let's just let's just do another giant
leap and from people who have apparently
spoken to other people who have
apparently tried the new model or a
precursor to the new gpd4 they say that
gpt4 will be just as much an improvement
over gpt3 as gpt3 was over gpt2 and if
you remember in case you remember gpt3
was a giant improvement over gbt 2 now
is this going to be AGI and solve all
our problems probably not but in case
this is true in cases it is really the
same amount of Step from gpt2 to gpd3 as
it is from gpt3 to the new gpt4 then I
think we're in for pretty pretty amazing
times in any case rumors be rumors and I
guess we'll only know when we actually
see it the new model is rumored to be
released sometimes between December and
February so the wait isn't going to be
that long
related to this open AI is also rumored
to collaborate with cerebrus and
cerebrus in turn has just released their
biggest supercomputer to date which is
called Andromeda and has 13.5 million
cores now cerebras is a company that
builds extremely large chips they want
to do as much as they can like on a
single chip and that's why their chips
are like
I think they're about yay big I'm not
exactly sure but this absolute super
computer is just comprised of 16
cerebral CS2 systems so that should give
you an already an indication of just how
big their individual systems already are
now connecting them makes for a
ginormous super computer now here on the
website it says get demo but I guess for
most of you it's not really gonna be an
option to you know go into business with
this kind of scale but for some of you
it might be and you might very well want
to click that button
The Meta research blog announces the esm
metagenomic atlas the first view of the
dark matter of the protein universe so a
lot of folding work a lot of protein
folding work has been done recently with
Alpha fold and esm fold now meta
releases a database of what's called
metagenomics metagenomics is essentially
if you just go outside and you pick up a
piece of dirt there's going to be like a
ton of microbes a ton of bacteria a ton
of organic material in there and all of
that genomic material isn't necessarily
something you'd find in like the Human
Genome Project or something like this
yet it's still very important for
example for Ecology for medicine but
also for human well-being so this meta
genomic Atlas is the first database that
reveals the structures of the
metagenomic world at the scale of
hundreds of millions of proteins you can
explore that there is a link to the
atlas right here if you're anywhere near
this world of protein folding I guess
this is a very exciting time and I'm
also so excited for the progress we make
on other Frontiers rather than just
scaling up and producing more stories
about unicorns like for all the
criticisms that these big models get and
the pressure to just scale and scale and
scale they do every now and then deliver
us something like this something that's
absolutely undeniably useful for some
natural science out there and as we get
better with our core research even if
that's on pictures of cats I strongly
believe that this will greatly benefit
adjacent Fields such as biology
mathematics physics chemistry and more
of the other Sciences also on the meta
AI blog they released a blog post called
teaching AI Advanced mathematical
reasoning now I've dealt before with
some of the papers that meta had in this
regard where they tried to come up with
systems that use a prover so there are
these things called prover systems or
proof Assistance or essentially
formalize your whole mathematics inputs
so you'd spell out everything super
formally super descriptive super
detailed and then then you can use the
system to search for new proofs by
applying some proof strategies here and
there so you can say I want to do now a
contra position of two things and so on
however as you'll quickly discover the
amount of strategies that you can apply
to a given statement to search for a
proof is really really huge and that
leaves you essentially with a search
problem so this paper uses essentially a
variant of Monte Carlo tree search the
same thing that like alphago uses in
order to determine the next moves in a
go game in order to determine the next
proof strategy or the next proof step
that should be applied in order to reach
a given Target statement again very cool
that what initially dealt with a bunch
of games and was really flashy because
we can also go and chess much better has
developed into something that is of
actual use in an adjacent field in this
case mathematics so very cool check out
the paper if you are interested
Nvidia has released a paper called e
diff I a text to image diffusion models
with Ensemble of expert denoisers this
is I would say a typical Nvidia paper
where they don't reinvent the world but
what they do is they take what exists
and they apply a strong engineering
mindset to it they improve upon it and
it just results in a very high
qualitative output so in this case they
take the idea of these text to image
diffusion models but then on top of that
they have an ensemble of expert
denoisers so they don't just have one
denoiser like we'd be used to in a
diffusion model they have an ensemble of
denoisers which means that different
models can take care of different phases
in this denoising process also they
stage the image production in multiple
steps now this has been done before but
it is a very viable strategy in that you
essentially have one model produce a low
resolution version of the image and then
you successively scale that up now as
you can see right here all in all that
results in super high quality quality
images that can either be done from a
text description or from as you can see
right here text plus some kind of map or
some kind of mask that you draw or over
here you can also input some sort of a
style reference image into the system so
again it's just amazing how people are
able to push forward the state of the
art in such a short time
big science has released two new models
one called blooms and the other one
called mt0 These are evolutions of their
previous models and they're mainly
concerned with multi-task prompted fine
tuning we've dealt with prompted
fine-tuning before in the Galactica
paper which essentially means that after
you pre-trained your model you fine tune
it on prompted samples so like you would
ask gpt3 with a prompt to do some kind
of task you go ahead and actually fine
tune on the prompt the input and the
output of that task to make the model
learn to respond to such prompts in an
appropriate fashion and if you do that
for multiple tasks you also have the
ability to then generalize to new tasks
because that will carry over from the
pre-training specifically these new
models deal with this exact setting but
in non-english data so across lingual
generalization doing this in multiple
languages and potentially also
generalizing across languages the models
are on hogging face if you want to check
them out
iClear 2023 reviews are out on open
review and there are quite a few
surprises in the negative Direction so
Robert Tang here tweets out an example
where the authors respond to a reviewer
with response to you is a waste of time
I hope you can respect the author's work
and give constructive comments instead
of taking a few minutes to give a
trivial suggestion I recommend that you
complete a university maybe kindergarten
course before giving your review
comments that's just lovely somehow
believing in the good of human beings
maybe this person just like had an
absolutely terrible day and they really
need this paper and the review is
actually very very bad like actually
does make like a super trivial dunk on
the paper and you know I'm not sure what
happened right here if you're ever
inclined to write the rebuttal like this
just don't just sleep go to sleep wake
up the next day breathe and realize that
it's it's kinda useless even if it's
probably true another worrying issue
tweeted out by Stella biederman is the
following so One reviewer criticized
this model for that it is not acceptable
to only compare with publicly available
models meaning that the paper should
also have compared with non-publicly
available models now there is of course
a debate to have right here in order to
properly compare to someone's model you
need to have access to it on the other
hand there has been a long history of
science where people just hadn't been
putting stuff out into open source and
you'd essentially just have to take the
numbers from the tables from their paper
and then put those into your paper and
essentially just believe what they said
it's possible that the reviewer here is
of the stance that look you know you can
just take the number that they claim and
put them there on the other hand it's
also entirely fair to say that well I
don't have access to their model I can't
verify their numbers and therefore I'm
not going to put them into my paper the
Crux is obviously if that fact that you
leave these things away and that orange
public also makes your method appear a
lot better in comparison because the
only actual competitors to your method
are closed source and only have some
number and some paper I don't know
what's the correct answer right here but
it's certainly worth having a discussion
about and lastly and you might actually
have heard of this one is this paper
called variance reduction is an antidote
to byzantines better rates weak
assumptions and communication
compression as a cherry on the top
people do get creative with titles these
days but the problem that One reviewer
here had is with the word byzantines
which the reviewer claimed to be a
disparaging of the whoever people
consider themselves Byzantine now
Byzantine is a term that's been long
used in various fields of analysis a
security cryptography I believe Game
Theory so the term is very well known
and is an established technical term
however the reviewers of strong opinion
that that is a term that contains
Prejudice and his derogatory and is
denouncing the ethno-religious practice
of some people now the reviewer bases
their opinion strongly on the fact that
the iClear code of ethics says You must
respect cultural heritage of others and
repeatedly claims that the usage of the
term Byzantine in this work is a
violation of the iClear code of ethics
whereas the authors claim this is a
technical term it's been used for a long
time and it is disparaging to absolutely
no one and the conversation goes on and
on I believe there are over 36 comments
in this thread including some other
people coming in and saying hey I'm
actually considered Byzantine and I
don't have a problem with the term so
don't defend you know us while the
reviewer did make some suggestions for
other terms such as deviant but the
authors pointed out that none of these
suggestions capture the term in its full
existence or in how people actually use
it as the debate goes on you'll see the
reviewer shifting their stance a little
bit from the fact that it's just not
appropriate to use the term that the
paper also isn't technically correct but
I strongly believe that the reviewers
only introduced that point after the
discussion had been going on for a while
and they realized they needed to make
another stronger case on scientific
terms now the problem here is that on
open review I believe you can't see the
modifications so we have no idea these
comments they were all changed around
even the original comment is changed
around to like include some other
feedback and so on so it seems the
timeline here is a little bit murky the
authors here also point out that this
point the point that the word Byzantine
is inappropriate was apparently
initially the only criticism of that
reviewer or the only real criticism but
the reviewer gave the paper a really low
score and if you know anything about
conferences most meta reviewers just
kind of look whether there is one bad
score and then the paper already has
very poor Chan chances or they look at
the average which would obviously be
decreased strongly by one bad score so
essentially the reviewer held the paper
hostage a little bit and wanted the
authors to change the wording the
authors even agree to abbreviate the
word Byzantine to Biz like the short
form Biz because they just didn't agree
that any of the other terms would do the
technical nature Justice the reviewer
disagreed that that would actually solve
the problem and essentially said that
even if they were to change the term
they would now expect not only to not
use that term but also the paper to
contain a discussion of why the word
Byzantine is not appropriate or at least
like a moral struggle of the authors or
bringing this up of why this is
problematic the reviewer again
repeatedly and insistently claims that
it violates the iClear code of ethics
and holds that as like a stick to the
like hit the authors with like code of
ethics this is against the code of
ethics what's interesting is that at
some point the the program chairs
commented on this as well saying that
the program chair committee and ethics
chair have been following This Thread
closely upon preliminary investigation
the ethics chair find that the use of
the b word it's not the b word is it
possibly emerging issue but not yet a
major ethics issue that could justify
rejecting research there seems to be no
widespread agreement that the b word is
offensive this discussion between
reviewers and authors is still valuable
to your community which raises awareness
of this potentially emerging issue we
appreciate the thoughts from the reviews
and they said that this is essentially
now resolved by saying you know reviewer
you made your point but we don't agree
with the point the reviewer responded
again lengthily pointed out that this
violates the iClear code of ethics now
in the end you could say it's all good
and the program chairs came in and
essentially squashed the reviewer and
said okay the paper is fine you can use
the word Byzantine it's not problematic
all good but I strongly actually believe
that this is a Big Win For This reviewer
right here because the ethics chair the
appropriate response would be shut off
you're an embarrassment to the
scientific institution and you're barred
from reviewing any more papers for any
other conferences this is a joke shut up
but they didn't do that they essentially
said yes to the reviewer they
essentially said yes it's a possibly
emerging issue because they've seen that
there was quite a bit of uproar in the
community that's such a what is
essentially a technical term that is no
one absolutely no one except this
reviewer feels is not appropriate was
used the Essex chair said yes it's
possibly emerging so this is like a
groundwork for the future this is how
these things slip in there I have full
conviction that people who write these
codes of Ethics do so with the best
intentions at least most of them I do
believe some of them predict exactly
this and this is how you again and again
slip these things in so one person makes
a fuzz you you take the temperature of
the community it's like ah not yet ready
but we have now precedence right so at
the next conference the same reviewer
can make a fuzz again and they can point
back and say well other people you don't
know it's the same review other people
have said this before so actually this
might actually be problematic and the
ethics chair here seems to be bound by
the fact that someone said this is
ridiculous shut up however they do so in
the most lenient way in the most way
that guarantees that in the future this
will actually become a problem so in my
opinion big win for the reviewer right
here big win for the complainers and I
don't like it
Google has a new paper called
efficiently scaling Transformer
inference on how they scale their big
home models on tpus now it is not going
to be very applicable for most of you
but in case you care on how they enable
something like 32 larger context lengths
and super duper flops and super duper
Hardware utilization during large batch
process sing give this paper a read also
from Google The Google research Blog has
an entry called infinite nature
generating 3D fly-throughs from still
photos this is on top of a paper that
they published at eccv which generates
infinite views or infinite fly-throughs
as the title says and the cool thing is
this happens from still images so you
can give a single image and it will
generate a fly through from that image
they use various techniques for that but
the base idea is that you take an image
and you predict its depth map so how far
away all the stuff is and then you use
that in order to render the image from a
slightly different view if you know how
far away all the things are you can
position your camera slightly
differently and you can still determine
where the pixels go now this will leave
some pixels to be undetermined because
you can now see behind things that you
didn't see before and then you have
another model here in this refine step
that essentially fills in these missing
pixels and then you repeat again you
pose the depth map you adjust your
camera position tiny bit and then you
fill in the pixels that are missing in
order to train this it's not exactly
super easy but there are some various
techniques called cycle consistency or
what they do right here they have an
adversarial setup they have a
discriminator to determine whether after
a number of steps the image still looks
like it's been generated from a real
like nature image and if you back
propagate that error then you can
generate very long very high quality
fly-throughs through nature here you can
see a bunch of examples what I do find
interesting is that they also added a
specific Sky model in order to make you
feel like the sky is more real I suspect
their original works that the sky was
often the problem and looked unrealistic
so now everything that sky here is
produced actually by a separate model as
far as I can tell
paella I hope that's how you pronounce
it is a new paper that also does text to
image however this one is speed
optimized so in order to do diffusion
you have to take some bit of noise and
then run it through the diffusion
process step after step after step there
are various techniques to speed this up
and Paya supercharges them and manages
to do the whole diffusion process in
only 10 steps which amounts to only 500
milliseconds So within only 500
milliseconds you have a high quality
image from a given piece of text again
amazing progress in a field that is
super young check out paella there's
corresponding paper to it called Fast
text conditional discrete denoising on
Vector quantized latent spaces
now if you enjoyed the previous paper on
how to scale up Palm then you might also
enjoy multi-ray which is by meta and the
blog post is called optimizing
efficiency for a large scale AI models
this describes the system called
multi-ray I've read the blog post and I
have to say it's kinda wishy-washy you
have to guess a lot of the stuff they
just kind of describe in words what it
does and they link to various things
that they've done but I can't exactly
read out you know what precisely they're
doing right here but if you need some
inspiration of how a system like this
would work or you know some hints of how
this is really done in practice at scale
and give this blog post a read
archive pairs up with hugging face so
previously hugging face has acquired
hugging face spaces from gradio which
allows you to make little demos out of
your hogging face repositories and now
archive includes those spaces so if you
upload a paper to Archive you can attach
a demo from a hugging face space so
people can directly on archive try out
your model if you have one or your
Technique if you have one and do so
interactively this is very cool and
obviously I'm a big fan of integrating
interactive things into our very old
format of eight page PDFs
[Music]
okay we got a bunch of new models this
week the first one is alt diffusions by
flag AI which is a multi-lingual
diffusion model so this is essentially
stable diffusion but multilingual as you
can see right here English Chinese
Spanish French Russian Japanese Korean
Arabic and Italian next is dmox by meta
which is a music Source separation model
so this thing you can put like a song in
there and it will separate the sources
meaning it will separate things like
drums and vocals and isolate those
perfect for practicing something doing
karaoke and whatever you want to do with
it the paper is called hybrid
Transformers for music Source separation
and it's an archive there's a new
multilingual clip available from Lion
trained on their own data set the lion
5B and it reaches 77 zero shot on
imagenet in English and around 55 for
Italian Japanese and Chinese and
supports over 100 languages the cool
thing is that it's very efficient the
training because it uses locked image
tuning which we've discussed previously
in a video so check out the model and
check out locked image tuning if you
haven't seen it yet it is really cool
paper and a cool and simple technique in
other news a research group at the
citizens University of New York has
released a model that can accurately
predict the human response to novel drug
compounds now they're certainly not the
first people to release such a model
this has obviously been going on for as
long as data science has existed but
also it's cool to see that even in this
front in the drop Discovery front giant
progress is being made on the back of
what started out as cat image research
alright some helpful things for this
week we have quite a lot to get through
so let's get into it this is a pixel art
Sprite sheet generator if you're into
old games into Sprite animations and so
on this is a stable diffusion based
model that will create the Sprites for
you given a description look at this I
typed in Fat Joe prompt extend is a
model that will extend your prompts so
here is an example you type in
psychedelic liquids space and it will
append what it thinks that stable
diffusion needs to give you what you
want so this is like a little bit of a
translator between human input and
whatever a very competent human using
stable diffusion could do with all the
modifiers such as concept or sharp Focus
illustration Unreal Engine and so on
there's a new blog post on hugging face
telling you how to fine-tune whisper or
multilingual ASR but you can fine tune
whisper for whatever you want this blog
post is your point of entry dream
texture is a plugin to make blender
interact with stable diffusion so here's
a demo person types into blender
whatever they want as a texture in terms
of text and then boom apply and it's now
in the texture absolutely great the
YouTube channel Mutual information has a
series on reinforcement learning that I
can highly recommend they spend a lot of
time on this and I hope it is helpful to
anyone who's looking to get into RL
lovely tensors solves a problem we all
have had in the past so if I just want
to print some tensor I'm gonna get this
and it's absolutely not helpful at all
as soon as your tensors go beyond like
four or five values it's useless to just
look at them so all you do is you import
lovely tensors you monkey patch that
stuff in and all of a sudden if you
print a tensor a numpy array a torch
tensor whatever it will give you the
shape the amount of elements statistics
means the standard deviations and so on
this is a much much better way to look
at tensors now if the tensor is small
enough it will actually show you the
values but as soon as it's bigger than
that it will give you much more useful
information so here it warns you that
there is Infinities there's nands in the
tensors and so on and even here it tells
you well this one is actually all zeros
you can still get back to the original
tensor using sort of property access
here you have verbose access that will
give you the values even if it's large
and here you get the just the plain old
way if you really want that there are
various helper methods around this also
to show images to show statistics to
show channels and to show things such as
different filters in a stack of
convolutional filters I'll leave you to
explore all of that yourself but if you
work with tensors a lot in an
experimental sense this is surely worth
it GPT index is a technique to build an
index out of files using GPT so this
uses GPT to essentially take a bunch of
files and then for example recursively
summarize them so that you essentially
have a structure where you have a
summary on top of a bunch of stuff and
then if you like one of them you go into
it and then you have summaries of the
sub stuff that is there you go into that
it's kind of an experimental I want to
say this is a bit of a new way of
thinking about what we could do with
these models in order to organize
information now that we have generative
capabilities and I like that people
think out of the box so if you're also
interested check out this repository
there's a new upscaler for stable
diffusion made by Riverside Wings The
Notebook is by and Shepard and compute
has been sponsored by stability AI The
Notebook here runs you through the whole
process of up sampling and it gives
really cool results I've previously
talked about dags Hub Dax Hub is like a
bit of GitHub for machine learning and I
know a lot of places claim this nowadays
but axub really believes in the open
source Paradigm and now they release
something they call Direct data access
and essentially a technique to stream
down and upload version data to some
place they essentially connects a DVC
which you might know as like a data
versioning tool with a transparent
approach where you don't need to like
pull all the whole data at once or you
know stream it in some custom way you
can just treat it as if it already
existed and magically the library in the
background will pull down the data as
you need it in a streamed fashion so no
long waiting on data to arrive you can
just simply let go train and even if you
don't have space for the whole data it
will still work now I don't have exactly
time here to explain you all of the
things that you can do with it but the
install is really simple you essentially
install their Hooks and everything works
just transparently and magically so if
you're interested check it out and also
check out their blog it's regularly
updated for example here is how to build
an end-to-end active learning Pipeline
with fully open tools GN is a GPU
environment management tool lets you
easily control configure and monitor the
GPU resources that you are using and it
is intended to ease up the process of
GPU allocation for data scientists
without code changes so this is in case
you're in some lab and you share gpus
with others this tool is a must have I
wish that this had existed during my PhD
it manages local gpus remote gpus
cluster gpus and so on you can reserve
gpus free up gpus essentially whatever
you want to do it has even a vs code
plugin so if you're at all using gpus
and especially if you're sharing them
consider this tool
mbxp is a multilingual Benchmark for
code completion in 10 plus programming
languages Tsai is an open source package
intended for applying deep learning to
time series on top of pytorch and fast
AI colossal AI has released two blog
posts both pertain to better and faster
and cheaper training of models the first
one is what they call aigc AI generated
content which essentially means image
generation models and the second one is
for structure prediction of protein
monomers and multimers and both times
they're able to speed up these models by
a lot now the code is openly available
so do go go and check it out and the
performance gains here are not only
during inference like we saw before but
this in fact provides for example for
stable diffusion 6.5 times faster
training and pre-training cost savings
so the hardware cost of fine tuning can
be almost seven times cheaper than if
you were to do it in the vanilla way
appvid is a benchmark for tracking any
point in a video super gradients is an
awesome library to build train and
fine-tune production-ready deep learning
state-of-the-art Vision models now we've
seen a lot of libraries that you know
claim to just make stuff better if
you're into Vision I believe having like
a library that's specific for vision
such as semantic segmentation or
bounding box prediction or even image
classification it really pays off to
have a library that's dedicated to your
field especially if it's something like
Vision where we have a lot of custom
techniques that make these models just
so much more efficient and better but
not only that super gradients also
provides a lot of pre-trained
checkpoints so even if you're just into
using some models this Library might be
good for you shumai is a network
connected differentiable tensor library
for typescript and JavaScript as you can
see in this demo what you can do is you
can define neural networks in typescript
and then you can distribute them over
multiple places over multiple machines
and you can use the await like the async
awaits syntax from JavaScript in order
to ship data to some other machines or
call some function on another machine
and the library handles everything from
you from forward propagation to back
propagation and training it's really
cool and the API for this looks quite
clean safe tensors by hugging phase is a
new format who store and load answers
safely I previously done a video where I
showed how you can like smuggle a remote
code execution into the hugging face Hub
because the models essentially use the
pi torch loading function and pytorch in
turn uses the pickle function by python
which executes arbitrary code safe
tensors is supposed to alleviate that by
defining a safe fixed and simple format
to store tensors now obviously the
trade-off here is that you can't store
arbitrary things anymore if you want to
store arbitrary things you have to allow
arbitrary code to be executed so while I
expect that a lot of architectures might
switch to something like safe tensors it
is not a full solution for the problem
For Better or Worse research will come
up with new things new ways of doing
things and if you constrain yourself to
a particular way of doing things then
that will always not be enough however
it's mostly gonna be enough Velo is a
learn Optimizer and the cool thing here
is that it really seems to be better
than or at least on car with very
hand-tuned optimizers so you might know
optimizers as stochastic gradient
descent or Adam or something like this
but it is possible to learn an Optimizer
so to learn a system that controls the
optimization behavior of a training run
of another system these people have
taken a lot of different ml problems a
lot of different networks have run
optimization problems on them and have
essentially learned an Optimizer that
optimizes all of these different
problems well so that's what we consider
a learned Optimizer and this one really
seems that for many problems especially
like mainstream problems it works really
really well out of the box so without
you having to tune you know the beta 2
parameters and the learning rate and
stuff like this you just apply it in its
default configuration and it does a
pretty good job this is super important
if you want to do rapid prototyping
rapid exploration of some new ideas
without doing a giant grid search
overall the parameters the Merlin data
loader is data loader specifically for
recommender systems recommender systems
have you know few extra or a few special
requirements namely there's often quite
few data I want to say compared to some
thing like an image classifier like the
data points are mostly tabular and
they're not as many so loading from disk
and loading like Pairs and stuff from
disk often can become the bottleneck so
a data loader is super important here
and the Merlin data loader promises to
be over 10 times faster over native
framework data loaders if you're into
recommender system try this out Loda is
an Assembly Language a computational
model and a distributed tool for mining
programs this topic is very far away
from me but some of you might actually
be interested so if you're into integer
sequences there are these online
encyclopedias of integer sequences like
one two three four or five and so on so
there's sequences of integers and the
question is always what's the program
behind them like can I come up with a
piece of code that produces that integer
sequence into perpetuity and you know
one two three four five is quite simple
but it gets complicated very quickly and
especially to teach machines to come up
with the rules behind the a sequence is
very challenging problem so Loda is a
system that allows you to mine such
programs essentially you can run it and
it will crank crank crank crank and
intelligently search for these programs
but not only that it is also a
distributed tool for doing that so you
can distribute you can partake in mining
of such programs and much more so as I
understand this is about what a loader
program looks like or what it searches
for so here you can see one of these
sequences and this is apparently the
program it comes up with it looks pretty
interesting if you're interested uh
check loader out
is a library for geometric algebra in
Jax and numpy if you're into geometric
algebra here's the example of a rigid
body physics engine with a constrained
solver then this Library might be for
you mteb is a benchmark for text
embedding this is from similar authors
as the buyer Benchmark which is a
retrieval and Mark but this goes further
this is a benchmark that covers eight
embedding tasks over 56 data sets and
112 languages and it also evaluates in
this paper already 33 models on that
Benchmark so the goal here is to find
the one unified text embedding that
covers all Downstream tasks and the
status this far is that that Universal
embedding hasn't been found yet the
leaderboard shows that some models are
good at some tasks other models are good
at other tasks so the Holy Grail of text
embedding is still somewhere out there
and this Benchmark might prove that you
have found it okay the last cool thing I
want to show you is not bot and this is
already a little bit older than that
Friedman tweeted this out in September
but essentially he managed to connect
gpt3 to the browser to a web browser and
just let it interact with the web
browser by prompting it in an
appropriate way you know given the
website's HTML structure so apparently
the original idea comes from Sharif
shamim and that bot has a repository on
GitHub look it's just one python file I
know half of you are super cringing
right now but you know Research b
research and if you want to figure out
how it's done Hana what works and if you
want to give it a shot yourself might be
really cool to do so please do alright
that was all from ml news this was a big
chunk thank you so much for being here
thank you for supporting the channel
come to Discord if you're not already on
it link is in the description we have
fantastic paper discussions every week
and we talk General machine learning
every day with that being said stay
hydrated bye bye
foreign